I
turn off my noise gate.
Can you hear how?
Empty.
Goa, goa, goa.
If I come over here.
Far away.
So far away.
No furniture.
I have.
I have two furniture.
And no, I have, wait, in this room, I have a desk, and
that's it.
Housewarming, next is it, goo.
Glad you're getting settled into your new place.
I am, I missed you guys.
I missed you guys.
In here, I have a chair and I have my table.
Actually, this is supposed to be my table for patrons.
for patrons, but actually I'm using it for my own stuff.
I missed you guys.
Oh, refresh chat, oh, it's gonna be doing this all the time.
Wait, oh, can I move, how can I move my mic a little bit?
Everything's all funky.
Everything's all funky, funky fresh.
It's so strange for me.
Whoa.
Am I lagging?
Why am I lagging?
Oh, maybe because my phone is dying.
Two FPS.
Or it could be the computer.
Everything is confusing.
Wait, Isaac, are you on fire?
Oh, it's a little on fire.
Charge it?
I lost the cable.
I lost the cable!
Oopsie.
I have to find, I have to get another one.
Or find it, who knows.
MT can only hear Mito, just like my hand.
Finally, Mito has a warehouse.
Oh, uh...
What?
Wait, what's special about having a warehouse?
What's special about a warehouse?
Thank you guys for the super chats, by the way.
Thank you so much.
I'm trying to click on some of these so I can read.
Paying the cute Mito tags.
There is no such thing.
There's no such thing.
But I will, this today's stream will be a little bit short.
I'm currently living the life, the afterlife actually, of a
sad person with no bed.
And I must assemble my bed.
Right now, It is but a mattress.
No, but I have, I have like nothing, everybody.
I made, I made a dresser yesterday.
That was pretty tough.
I think the bed will be even.
Peak male living space.
Yes!
And also, my AC is broken.
But it will be fixed soon.
Um, I just...
be fixed soon i just oh oh not yet so i'm cook i'm cooked i
have
it is a summertime so sorry i cannot stream for so long
because i will become like an egg my ectoplasm will you know
when you cook an egg the jelly parts of the ectoplasm will
become egg-like hope your move will wow me though i hope
Erasing gets fixed soon.
It was my birthday last week.
Woo!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
Am I moving smooth now?
I can't tell, actually.
I can't tell also if it's my internet.
Or if it's...
My computer.
Because I won't have my actual computer for a couple more
weeks.
We're lagging?
Uh-oh.
Slightly laggy.
Okay.
A little choppy.
Yeah, I'm on my mini PC.
I'm going to get rid of chat.
Because it's just going to freeze again.
Smack!
Thank you!
Well, that's why we...
That's why I also today's short.
So I can test how things are.
And then...
Here, I'll put...
Hold on.
Let me put...
replacement I'll fix things later hopefully this is not how
it will always be though hopefully because I'm only my mini
PC let's see
one tick one tick I'm putting you in the chair get chaired
get chaired what have you guys been up to What have I
missed?
Oh, what have I missed?
What have I missed?
Waiting for you.
Yeah?
You saw Vicky last weekend.
I saw your tweets.
I did, I did.
I started playing Subnautica.
Fun?
FIFA!
FIFA, FIFA, FIFA 4-fum.
Actually.
Then when I was, when I was, you know, probably alive,
everybody said FIFA, I 4-fum.
And now everybody just skips to FIFA.
We have lost the plot that...
Everybody is in too rush of the world.
And they can't even say FIFA 4-fum anymore.
You have to just say FIFA.
And that's it.
She cherishes us.
I finished leaving I finished my bachelor's degree Glad
Jammin Congratulations Congratulations
Now time to go for the biggin The Masters The FIFA Masters
She despises us Why would you say that?
Why do you think that, huh?
FIFA Fofom.
Good afternoon.
Good evening.
Is there anywhere that's morning?
What time is it in Japan?
Hey there!
Oh, hiyao gozaiimasu.
Got my Denzitsu happy merch today.
I just have to glue on a minky dress ribbon, which snapped
and chipping.
No, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Per our usual tradition, we got lonely while you were gone
and made femme weeping.
What is that?
Back from my trip so I can catch Minto live consistently
again.
I miss you so much.
Look at that.
Welcome back.
Oh, yeah.
Streams will still be a little inconsistent for me.
They'll be more consistent once I get my actual PC set up,
which will be in a couple weeks, unfortunately.
No, not a couple weeks.
Like a week.
Like a week and a half.
I'm without much furniture and without much of my stuff for
a week and a half.
I just got my student loans fully discharged.
Let's go!
Congratulations!
Congrats!
Just in time for AX.
I know!
Is anybody going to Anime Expo?
There will be a meet and greet.
You could come to the Iron Mouse and friends.
Meet and greet.
Densatsu will be there.
Good morning Vietnam.
Good morning, Vietnam!
I'll be going just one day.
Yeah, Blue Archive will be there.
too yeah yeah go you wish you were going to anime expo i
don't think i ever wish i'm going to anime expo sorry i hmm
anime expo is one of those things that just makes you be
like almost feels like a nest not a necessary but it is like
a oh you get the foam mold but then you when you go when you
actually go there you're just like oh gosh no well thank you
so much welcome back we don't miss you so much i hope i had
a i hope i had a stressless moving missed it all you all
i've missed it yeah my wallet is crying but that's okay i've
almost gotten everything that i need um i think so Oh,
Marco, thank you so much for the five good days.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
My friend convinced me to go this year.
I haven't been since 2014, it's going to be hell.
Oh gosh, good luck.
Since 2014?
I mean, that was still pretty bad then too.
I worked my last day today as a contractor, starting next
Monday, I'll be full time.
I'll be getting a bigger paycheck, I'm real better than last
day!
huge congrats congratulations 2014 was 20 years ago actually
it was 100 years ago actually there was no no electricity in
2014 crazy technology has just exploded in the past 100
years wallet never cried yeah well maybe my wallet's crying
my savings is crying hold on everybody stay hydrated trying
to win actually you can't tell but
today's main dress is a little different because it is made
of a fabric that is from muji do you guys know muji do you
guys know muji because muji is it's It is a store.
It's like a home store.
It's like, it's like they have clothes and they have home
goods and they're very like minimalistic type.
It's very, yeah, good basics.
They do, they do.
It's very minimalistic type of stuff.
But, but this is a huge thing.
This is my osusume for you all for this summer.
outfits from Muji clothing is, is, you can sweat, you can
sweat, but it does not show up on the outside.
So if I look at my armpits right now, sweat, but you can't
see it on the outside.
Yeah, Asian IKEA is like a great way to explain it, I think.
What it will do is my sister is pregnant.
I'm so happy to soon become a father.
A father?
Uncle.
Papa?
Ghost don't sweat.
That's ectoplasm.
It's true.
But the point is, is that even if you spill water on the
inside of your shirt, if you have...
ectoplasm we have sweat if you have some other fluid that is
mysterious and you are not sure of the contents or where it
came from you can say you can you can wear this shirt nobody
would know that you have that inside what if you just like
to pour water down your shirt but you feel judged all the
time because you say I poured water down my shirt now
everybody will see it on the outside I know you could do
that.
And nobody would know.
And you would feel really great, probably.
It's from Mooji.
I suggest it.
It works.
She said the beam.
Happy Garfield Day.
Can I get a happy birthday for our feline?
Is it Garfield Day?
Oh, and I guess for me.
K-born!
Happy birthday, K-Garf.
You are now...
You are now the K-Garf.
I missed you, Vicky.
I missed you, too.
Mudi, it'll hide your leaks.
Papa, can you hear me?
Papa, can you see me?
What is that from?
Wow, did you hear that?
Hold on.
Listen to my water bottle.
I'll turn off the...
Wow!
Goop.
I've been requesting minus two.
I don't listen to that asking the store clerk for the mint
phantom outfit where you can pour water inside and no one
can tell is she spilling water down her shirt you'll never
that's my secret I'll never tell exo-exo gossip ghost
reporting for pedal fan duty boss yeah please please did you
hear about k becoming the queen of summer comic i did the
amount of k from blue archive at summer comic care is gonna
be crazy but also if you were planning on going to summer
comic care you should go or if you weren't got to get all
the K merch.
It was so sad.
There was like two Koharu things.
So sad.
UK Ibu's have successfully bullied Steiner at TTT.
Perfect.
Good.
You've done your job.
You should try that with the normal t-shirt.
Ha ha.
JK.
Oh my gosh.
What if my shirt was white?
No.
You would see my band-aids.
Is there any way for people who don't live in Japan to
participate in the comic kept hype from home?
Well, there are sites like Mellon Books.
They will ship to...
The books will be put onto Mellon Books, Toro No Anna, so
you could always find what you want there.
So no.
It's not quite the same, but Minky anti-wet shirt plot
device.
No, wait a second.
What if the world turns to ash and also turns to using only
this type of fabric for everything?
And then wet t-shirt contest becomes extinct!
And then I never get to experience one!
Wait a second.
Oh, no!
Scrap that.
We need to tell Moji this is such a bad idea.
No!
We need to tell Mujie.
That this is a tragedy.
Dear John Mujie, stop making that shirt.
You don't know what you've unleashed.
I made a huge discovery.
I managed to make a Taco Bell Baja blast.
That ghost can drink.
My first testers was ghosts from an old hotel.
How does it work?
I'm curious.
I'm very curious.
Very curious.
Let's see.
What can I say?
I can't say much about my new cafe.
I can say that I really, really like it.
Minus the part that I don't have the AC working.
But hopefully for future streams.
Oh, what else?
I can say that there is a great bubble tea place.
within floating distance.
So I will haunt there pretty often, maybe.
Are your stream time staying the same?
Well, yes.
That's why I'm streaming right now, no?
I am in a new time zone.
But I am.
That's why I'm streaming right now, no?
Yeah.
Are the cats doing well in the new cafe?
Unfortunately, my cats could not come with me.
So I missed him very much, actually.
Wait, you're streaming now?
Crazy, right?
It's very echoey.
Yeah, I have no furniture.
I have no furniture.
Actually, the only thing, wait, is it really that echoey?
Can you tell so much?
What I was going to say is right now my room is full of
cardboard boxes.
Would you do a karaoke while the cafe is still empty for the
acoustics?
Okay, we can do it right now.
Let's sing, baby.
Wait, I don't even need to do...
Wait, can you tell so much?
A little.
Like this!
Ha ha!
Then maybe.
Oh, Google.
I have no furniture and I must watch the TV.
Oh, yeah, I have a, I got a TV.
I got a TV.
And you know what's really frustrating is going to get a TV
nowadays because they all have this, like, strange AI
smoothing on it that does not smooth.
In fact, it does the opposite.
makes things very choppy and so no cats allowed at all no i
i plan on getting a cat in the future yes yes yes um but so
thing i had to end up getting was like a roku tv because it
was the only thing that looked good on the display
everything else was choppy and terrible and i was like how
is it that the roku tv was the only thing that that worked
but all i'm gonna do is watch youtube on it anyway um maybe
play some games so roku tv nana no tv smoothing has been a
thing for a long time sadly how is it I haven't had to get a
TV, so...
I miss CRTs.
Yeah, right?
So...
Roku-na-na.
No idea if there's one near you, but MicroCenter usually has
deals on dumber TVs.
Oh!
Well, I mean, I already bought it.
bought it but you know have you pooped old today i haven't
shall we eat together let me set it up let me get a poop
doll up poop doll
daily word cam
all right one second one sec
la la la poop doll
oh it's wait is it called just poople i've been calling it
poop doll this whole time
oh wait i can't reach out hold on one second
there's two games wait did i open the wrong one wait hold on
wait a second i'm on poople oh here's poop doll wait one
second again i have to you do it?
Wait, this should be fine.
This should be fine.
Okay, wrong one, wrong one.
There we go.
Poop dog.
I can't believe there's multiple.
The world craves it, apparently.
Okay, so the idea is you have this word and you have to get
to poop, but you can change one letter at a time wait edge
eggie no eggie dang okay it's it actually is way harder than
then what you'd expect because every next word has to be an
actual word right so wait
Where's the undo?
Okay, never mind.
It says attempt one of three.
Yeah, edge is rough, right?
We could do edgy, but that doesn't...
Well, let's try it.
Edgy.
Okay.
I'm ending with a Y is great, I guess.
is tough though
i don't know if doing what will we go from eddie though you
guys where would we go from there you know
yeah if we went to eddie or eggy but from even eggy where
would we go from Where would we go from, Eggie?
Preggie?
No.
It's actually so hard.
Hope the movement well, Minto.
Minus the AC bar.
Yeah, thank you.
Hmm.
We could try Eggie.
And then eggs, yeah.
But
then...
Wait, did that just mess it up?
It's fine.
Probably.
Hmm.
I got it the first time.
Egos.
Now we have a poop.
I mean, O.
Sorry.
Let's see.
Wait.
I'm feeling I'm relying on you guys too much.
My brain is kind of cooked right now though.
We have an O.
We gotta keep that O.
Part of me wants to make, like, igloo.
You know?
Pros?
You could only change one word at a time.
Which would...
Oh, that would be great.
Wait, is arrows?
Oh!
Pros?
Poo's?
No!
But what if I have the poos?
Come on.
Prop.
Solid run poop in eight.
Yay.
Poop till in eight, everybody.
Par was seven though.
Par was seven.
I'm afraid I'm gonna
sneeze.
It disappeared.
My bad.
I hate when it does that too.
I hate when it does that too because my nose ends up getting
so stuffed.
Is my Oshi a subpar pooper?
No, my poop doll is peaked, please.
I don't have any tissues.
I have no tissue.
I'm not using the sleeve.
I'm looking around.
Maybe I couldn't.
Wait, I might have some.
Hold on.
I might have some outside.
Wait a second.
I'll go get some.
I'll look.
Oops, I just ripped it.
Wait, oh gosh, wait, oh no, no, I don't know my own
strength.
Wait, I get out with it.
Uh, bow my nose.
Why did my tongue have?
Why'd that happen?
Well, guys, how's it been going though?
Oh, I was gonna do some karaoke.
now let's sing a little bit we can we can we can sing just
rewatch the amazing digital circus I know I saw it was
premiering when I when I was about to start stream I was
like no way no way I'll have to watch it after this.
Wait, hold on.
I'm trying to fix my mic real quick.
Ouch.
Never mind.
I can't fix it.
It hurts my pinky.
My thumb is raw.
My thumb is rubbed raw from trying to do furniture.
No.
I watched Obsession the other day.
Did you like it?
I can't wait to go see it.
I want to do a watch-along of that one.
I want to do it.
I was watching Pre-Cure.
The detective one, right?
The stem is raw.
Session was awesome.
Yeah, I want to do.
Have you seen back rooms yet?
No, actually I was going to go the other night.
I was going to go the other night, but the Densetsu meeting
ended up taking two hours, so I would have missed it.
Sad, sad, sad.
Oh, Phoebe, wait.
You just did karaoke.
Hi.
Hello, everybody.
Oh, hello.
Winto, I hope you stay cool.
Thank you.
You too.
It's hot.
Thank you, guys, for the gift.
Thank you so much.
Targo, thank you, Sisi, thank you.
very much thank you very hello taste himself thank you
paperbacks thank you thank you
let's what shall we sing what shall we sing um we could sing
anything Phil thank you it'll be hot let's sing something to
keep us cool right oh what's something what's a what's a
song Hot to go!
I guess I could do that, huh?
Ice, ice, baby.
Hot to go into...
Into...
Songs that are cool.
Into... So we're hot to go right now because my AC.
One second, here we go.
Miki!
Oya bun!
Koo da!
What?
Thank you for the pink.
Let it go.
We could sing let it go.
All right, hold on.
Karaoke time in my acoustics.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
When I was leaving my last maid cafe, I looked back in the
empty rooms and I went, ooh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hannah Montana and
my old roommate was like what are you doing and I was like
Hannah Montana
her house she goes oh yeah well well yeah anyway five six
five six seven eight it's loud addiction
it's all in my head but I want nonfiction I but I'll take
this city.
Who can blame a girl?
Call me hot because it's really hot.
Baby, do you like this bee?
I made it so you dance with me.
It's like 199 degrees.
When you're doing it with me, doing it with me.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes.
Raise your hands out, body roll.
Dance it out, you're hot.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes.
With your hands now body roll H-O-T-T-O-G-O H-O-T-T-O-D-O
You can take me hard to go H-O-T-T-O-T-O-T-O You can take me
hard to go Well, I woke up, oh thank you That's ceiling I
try not to care But it hurts my feelings You don't have to
stare, come here Get with it No one's touched me there In a
damn hot Baby, don't you like this beat?
I made it so you sleep with me It's like 199 degrees When
you're doing it with me Doing it with me H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap
and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands on body roll
Dance it out, you're hot!
H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your
hands on body roll H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go
H-O-T-G-O-G-O You can take me hard to go What's it take to
get your number?
H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O You
can take me hard to go Was
anyone else hot?
Oh, it was just me.
You're coming home with me.
Okay.
It's hot.
Yay.
That didn't make me cool down at all.
In fact, it just made me, it made me more hot because I was
dancing around.
Mint is hot to go.
I am hot, though.
Your PC is melting.
is it actually wait no I'm not lagging am I?
I don't think so it's okay let it go okay let's do let it go
oh the stream stuttered actually it is like pretty warm it's
a toasty piece here right now it might have been YouTube it
could have been it could have been let it go let it let it
go oh wait don't post that into Google let it go karaoke
okay this is gonna get us cool everybody this is oh sorry my
mic is all like funkified right now so okay
sorry that's the intro to the the karaoke how Wow!
The snow glows white on the mountain tonight, not a
footprint to be seen.
Oh, I'm lagging.
Kingdom of isolation, and it looks like I'm the queen.
I'm gonna blow some air out of IPC now.
Well now they know!
They're
going to say, let the storm rage on, the cold never bothered
me anyway.
Oh, low battery!
My phone's about to die!
It's funny how some distance...
Makes everything seem small And the fears that once
controlled me
It's time to see what I can do To test the limits and break
through No right, no wrong, no rules for me I'm free Let it
go, let it go and sky
Here I stand And here I'll stay Let the storm rage on
My power flurries through the air Into the ground My soul is
spiraling in frozen fractals all around And one thought
crystallizes like an icy blast I'm never going back The past
is in the past Let it go, let it go And I'll rise like the
I said in
any way.
What's my sweat like?
You can't tell because...
Oh, wait.
That's not what you asked.
I was about to talk about my shirt again.
Wait, you said wipe my sweat on it.
No, you'll never know that I'm sweating because you couldn't
tell.
Because...
Because I'm wearing a shirt that won't show.
I'm
gonna get in an ice cube.
I'm gonna put it down down my shirt but you'll never know
you'll never know if I put it on my shirt down my shirt
sideways or whichever way
the cold never bothered me anyway so I have no ice I
actually froze a wet paper towel and that's currently that's
currently what I'm using is is a cold paper towel I'm going
to stick it in my pants.
Oh, yeah.
How does she keep delivering peak even with just a laptop?
It's not a laptop.
It's a mini micro computer.
And its size does not matter.
It's very powerful.
I probably should not.
I probably in the future for streams until I get my regular
PC back.
I will.
Bechibimento.
But I feel like I just wanted.
to be myself today.
Have you explored your new neighborhood yet?
I think it might be a good idea to get some ice cream.
Can we go get ice cream after this, you guys?
Please, please.
Oh my gosh, it's already melting.
It's already melting, you guys.
Wait, I'm gonna put it on my PC.
I can feel it melting on my PC.
Oh, well.
ice cream after this it's summer and it's it's high well it
wasn't so bad well it was pretty bad i just had like a bunch
of windows open and so but obviously if i'm streaming i'm
gonna be in my room and i'm gonna be i'm gonna be quiet i
need as much not sound to bounce off the walls as possible
Okay, sorry.
You're melting.
It's not water.
It's a frozen towel.
I keep napping through the daytime because it's been pushing
triple digits here.
Yuck.
Oh, should I sing one last song?
But I'll keep talking a little bit more.
What's another song that will keep us cool?
everybody what's another song for the winter times um oh oh
um my easy is broken too no jovi bear stay cool santa baby
okay oops santa baby
there we girl
Santa baby just let her say blind your dog tree for me been
an awful good girl Santa baby and so how are they on the
chimney tonight Oh, I'm feeling so cool.
Santa baby, a 54 convertible too, light blue.
I'll wait up for you dear.
Santa baby, hurry down the chimney tonight.
Think of all the fun I've missed.
Think of all the fellas that I haven't kissed.
Next year, I quit.
would be just as good if you check off my Christmas leaves.
Santa baby, what a yacht and really that's not a lot.
Been an angel all year, Santa baby and hurry down the
chimney tonight.
Santa honey.
I need the deed.
To a platinum mine, Santa baby.
Hurry down the chimney tonight.
Pudding, Santa Pudding.
Santa Pudding.
Fill my stalking with a duplex and checks.
Sign your ex on the line, Santa cutie.
And hurry down the chimney tonight.
Oh!
Oh, no, oh, but oh, come and try and buy.
Cross the best tree.
With some decorations bought at Tiffany's.
I really do believe in you.
Let's see it.
Oh, Santa baby, hurry down the chimney to now.
Hurry.
That's to come fix my AC, please.
Hurry up and fix it.
Oh.
I was like, what the heck's that sound?
Oh, thank you for my impromptu karaoke.
That was not quite karaoke.
Plus two.
Do you have a fan?
Funny thing.
I packed it in the thing that they are in the shipping box.
and so I don't have a fan and so I'm having one delivered it
was I thought it would come before before um before stream
but it didn't
so yeah I don't even have a fan I I'm it's pretty toast to
you guys so I think I'll I'll call it here.
Sorry, I know it's a short YAP stream.
But thanks for I'm gonna try and stream again on Sunday.
And Sunday I would like to do a game.
So we'll game and we'll have fun.
It will be like a normal stream on Sunday.
So yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
I'm gonna go get ice cream.
not a single fan yeah so i'm so lonely i'm so lonely thank
you for sharing your wiki ice cream tie i was so good to
have you back yeah i'm glad that i could set up everything
and get my my internet working i only had to spend time on
the talking to my isp company for like an hour and a half so
it honestly wasn't even that bad
yeah and my pc is toasty so i'll let it rest now thank you
everybody thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you yeah not too bad not too bad thank you everybody
thank you thank you i will see you later
Probably next time, like I said, I'll be Chibi Minto until I
get my regular PC back.
And then we'll resume normal everything.
We'll resume normal everything.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.
Wait.
There we go.
Oh, it's a bit too.
Sorry.
I will still not have a schedule until my normal PC is back
though, because I've been I've been kind of like going off
and haunting and getting supplies and things that I need.
So it will still be a little erratic.
But I'll try to give you guys much more in advance heads up.
I just wasn't sure today if my internet would be working or
not at all.
So yeah.
Thanks everybody.
Bye bye.
Last lasagna.
Garfield.
Also pirate, thank you for the dono.
You know, wait, wait, oh wait.
Oh my gosh.
Remember how in the collab Doki was like, I hope you get
your visa.
Um, I hope you get your visa like the day you move you get
your last box or whatever that did not happen that did not
happen but I did get an email from the person yesterday and
they were like we know it's taking longer than normal
I was I got the email and I was like no no way no way um
also okay okay a bit of it i'm sorry i know i said i was
leaving i do want to say something real quick though um
because i saw i i i'm a little late to the saying this
because i wanted to say it on stream um it's a bit serious
it's a bit serious it's a bit serious here i'll even stop
the music it's a bit serious it's a bit serious um uh so i'm
sorry i'm late addressing this um i also uh didn't entirely
know what was going on because i've been um i'd been largely
offline but in no no pn no pn um in the fears for phallops
dream i was kind of you know lamenting about my poor luck
with getting the visa and everything um and you know uh some
people were uh or rather it i guess it kind of came across
to some people that i was uh upset that my former coworkers
were moving to Japan and that I was not and I truly that was
not my intention at all um in fact I'm very happy that uh
that my former company um would help people out more I'm
really sorry that it came off that way and I'm sorry that
they had to deal with any um you know backlash from that um
i uh you know i was just trying to joke about my bad luck
with the visa process um whoops sorry my phone's about to
die um so you know i really didn't mean for it to come
across that way and i'm really sorry um but you know uh i
understand that like you know um yeah if you were passionate
about something you want to you want to defend it you know
so um i understand that completely uh and um yeah i am very
happy for everybody that is that was able to do that it was
it was not i it was not me trying to complain about their
situation um them getting something that i didn't you know i
and i you know you know i am largely past it uh I think my
visa situation being as bad luck as I've had it in the past
couple of years.
I think it's mostly funny.
I, you know, I'm trying to roll with the punches of
everything and, you know, everything happens for a reason.
So if I, if I get it, if I move to Japan one day, I'm just
trying to realize my weeaboo dreams, you know.
So, but, you know, for clarification for, you know, anybody
that is curious, I was told during the hiring process, by
someone very very very high up in the company that they
would be able to do a visa for me and then later on when I
asked about it they said we've never heard of this we can't
do this for you and we're just so they said we can't and we
will not do this for you so you know I think anybody would
be a little frustrated about that but I've largely left it
left it in the past and just to you know just to not cause
any more confusion about my intentions in the future I won't
bring up my old workplace anymore I don't want to cause any
drama to anybody I don't want to cause any bad feelings to
anybody um I I honestly didn't know anything was happening I
actually saw some people tweeting about it and I was like
what's what's happening so um yeah I don't think it's I
largely moved on and i think um we're good to to just you
know move on as well and i'm wishing everybody that is still
there uh the best experience so um yeah i don't want to make
anybody i don't want to make anybody uncomfortable so yeah
that's all i wanted to say um you know and if oh you know my
former co-workers were upset of what i said as well i want
to apologize because again, it was not my intention and I'm
really sorry that I came across like spiteful, but it was
just me, more so me lamenting about my bad luck and, um,
and, you know, my bad timing and all.
So, um, yeah, okay.
Um, yes.
So that's, that's all I wanted to say.
That's all wanted to say just just to clear the air with
with with it all because um yeah uh i don't i i want to just
you know have have chill vibes and have good times so yes
yes yes um that's that's it okay sorry that i did say i was
gonna leave and that i did it but i did want to clear the
air with that one a little bit and kind of explain a little
bit more so yay ice cream time yes yes yes thank you
everybody thank you so much oh it's a way to oh it's a way
to eat it a day bye bye bye bye bye see you bye bye bye bye
for real for real now
sorry no lizard oh if you know actually I was thinking I
wonder I want you know the last lizard was PNG from Google
if anybody wants to draw a lizard PNG I would love to have
him on the screen you know if anybody wants to draw a lizard
and have the you know oh I would love to include as many as
possible what if we screen with lizards.
Lizard PNG.
Yes, please.
So, if anybody, you can post on my pantography.
Hashtag on Twitter.
I will include your lizard.
I feel so sad he's not there.
So, please.
Please, please.
Whoops, lizards.
Yes, yes.
You
asked, what if I get a A new kind of pet, a cold-blooded,
scaly animal.
Unfortunately, my place will not allow lizards.
Isn't that so sad?
I moved to a place where I can't get a lizard.
That's okay, though.
It is a specific, right?
They only allow cats and dogs.
I don't know why.
I feel like a lizard.
Oh, gosh, I would have watched him scamper across.
What about a Kinsle Kowatlus?
Yes, let me summon...
the DNA of a Kitzel and the pretzel.
What if the Kitzel DNA is in the pretzel?
You never know.
Has anybody tried that?
Who knows?
I just opened that.
Or the Akadono.
Thank you!
Yeah, no lizards.
A lizard and yeah, put it in a cat outfit.
They're like, this is my cat.
This is my cat.
And he looks and he's like, meow.
Thank you.